this summit is all about supercharging
the effort to protect people
and nature from the effects of a rapidly
heating planet
as well as the urgent need to reduce
emissions we also need to defend
ourselves as
already unavoidable impacts of climate
change unfold
we're seeing those impacts every day
this was mozambique less than
two years ago when cyclone idi killed
more than a thousand people
now literally today the country is again
picking itself up
after cyclone eloise swept through from
australia to california
wildfires are growing in intensity
destroying whole communities
add to this floods droughts sea level
rise
all threats we need to adapt to
adaptation is crucial
because more than 1 billion people
around the world are highly vulnerable
to climate change
and it is really a matter of intra and
intergenerational equity
the most vulnerable countries are those
that are least
responsible for the impacts of climate
change so this is
really about about climate justice
now many of the adaptation measures to
make people safer are
relatively cheap to implement from early
warning systems against storms to
regrowing coastal mangroves to provide a
natural barrier
against storm surges but hard cash
promised by richer nations to build this
resilience
well that's not been forthcoming it's
estimated funding
needs to increase tenfold to 300 billion
dollars a year
as part of an overall reset of the way
we live
it is not a choice of either the economy
or you know a terrible life it's not
because everybody's got to eat meat or
whatever choices are thrown around
this can be the greatest economic
transformation in global history
and just like the industrial revolution
this will be
the defining of a better quality of life
for our citizens over a long period of
time
climate-related disasters have cost 650
billion dollars globally in the last
three years
but it has been calculated that every
dollar spent on
adaptation prevents 12 of damage
while at the same time building
resilience against extreme events that
are already upon us
which impact the poor most of all